well now we have the idea of
multiplying matrices we'll see now that
a matrix is square
you can multiply it by itself and that's
going to give you the square matrix and
you can multiply it by itself again and
you're going to get the cube of a matrix
so basically you're going to have the
idea of matrix powers let's take a look
at that now
so of course it only makes sense sub a
is squared so
otherwise you can't multiply you know a
by itself or something like that
so if a is square then a squared simply
means a
a and the same for higher power so for
example a cubed
is a times a times a and as we know it
doesn't matter which order you
multiply it in so that's that's the that
would be and we're going to denote it as
a cubed now notice here that we're doing
some uh some overloading of notation
again
because if someone walks up to you on
the street and says
a cubed and a is a number then you know
what it is it's the cube of the number
you multiply the number by itself you
know three times right
um but here we're doing the same thing
except a is a matrix uh
so uh but it again makes perfect sense
so that these are the matrix powers
um now again uh to uh
to to it's going to be useful uh
to uh in in terms of the notation to
define
a to the zero as the identity now notice
that that's
like for a number raised to the zero
power
you get one and i is something
like i is something like the
matrix analog of the number one
well in fact of course when i is one by
one it is the number one
okay and if you do that then you get
this very nice thing that you know
that's an identity that you know holds
for numbers right that if i
if i multiply the kth power of a number
times the l power of a number i get the
k plus f
power of the number but the same is true
for me for for matrices as well a square
matrices if i take a square matrix i
take it to the k
power i multiply it by make the same
matrix to the lth power
i'm going to get the same the original
matrix to the k plus l power
okay now later in this in this book
and course we we're going to see
negative powers for example we're going
to see
you know a inverse uh which is going to
be well the inverse of the matrix that's
actually one of our next topics um
uh in more advanced courses you will see
weird things like
the square root of a matrix right like
you know a
to the one half right and you'll see all
sorts of other crazy stuff like that
we're not going to be talking about
fractional powers in in this course
although they do
they do come up uh in in in some
applications but we will be talking
about inverses
that's later for now we're just talking
about positive powers
or the zeroth power which by convention
is the identity of a matrix
so okay and why don't we just do a quick
example let's just start with like you
know 1
minus 1 to 0 that's a
and so a squared
in that case let's work out a squared
well that's going to be
1 minus 1 2 0
times 1 minus 1 to 0. you just simply
multiply the 2 together
and when i multiply that out the first
one gives me one
minus two that's minus one one times
minus one zero
is minus one uh this times that is two
times one plus that's going to be two
and this is going to be minus two
okay so the square
of this matrix is that matrix there
okay so just just just so we can see
what it what it looks like
okay so a lot of cool applications of it
we're going to look at one that involves
directed graphs
so actually you remember that several
lectures ago we looked at directed
graphs and we looked at the
nodes and edges there's another way to
describe
a directed graph which does not
explicitly enumerate
the edges so here's a directed graph
right here
actually they're they're closely related
if you look in the book you'll see how
the description when we enumerate and
label
the edges can be converted to this one
so that was the
incidence matrix this is the adjacency
matrix
okay and it's n by n
so here i have five nodes in my
graph and we simply define the adjacency
matrix of a graph this way
a i j is one if there is an edge from
vertex j to vertex i
notice it kind of goes backwards right
because a i j
you'd think it might be from i to j but
in fact it's from j to i
and i should also admit to you that
there are people who use the opposite
convention so that the adjacency matrix
is a i j equals one means that there's a
an edge from one to
from i to j but for us it's j to i
um okay and of course the two are just
related by transposing
okay so here's an example here's a
matrix
and now let's take a look at let's audit
a few things like
uh well we could do all sorts of cool
things here's an
here this edge goes from three to two
so uh that means that a
two three should have a one in it and
sure enough
it does let's go the other way let's
find
this that says that a
5 4 is 1 and that means there should be
an
edge going from node 4 to node 5.
let's see if that's true it is indeed
and that's the very edge it is
and let's just audit one more just to
make sure everything's cool here
let's audit this 0 here
that says that a 4
2 equals 0 and that tells us there is
not an edge going from node two to node
four
and that is indeed the case there is no
edge going from here
to here okay so that's the idea that's
that's the um
this is called the adjacency matrix of a
graph it's also by the way
absolutely standard mathematical concept
and kind of universal
okay now let's look at the square
of the adjacency matrix it's super
interesting
it is this um the
i j entry of the square of an edge
well of any matrix is this it's the sum
from k equals 1 to n a i k
akj but let's figure out what that means
well it says we sum over all
nodes and we take the product of akj
and aik but but these akj and aijs
a ik and akj they're either zero or one
okay
so basically usually this product is
zero
because one of them is zero or both of
them are zero okay
however there is a way when you get one
you get a one
if akj is one and a i k is one
but that has a specific meaning if akj
is one it says there's an
edge from j to k and a i k
is one that only hap that means there is
an edge from k to i
okay and so basically you get a one
whenever there is and there's there's an
edge
from j to k and also from k
to i now by the way two edges
that uh where one goes from one node to
another and then another one
starts from that node and goes to the
other one that's called a path of length
two okay so for example in this graph
you know let me get you a path of length
two here's one
you go from here to here and then you go
from here to here
so from there's a path from node five to
node two
of length 2 and you go along this edge
and then that edge
notice that the path has to go in the
direction of the arrow this is a
so-called directed graph okay so
uh what this says what our analysis up
here says is actually kind of amazing it
says that when you
square the adjacency matrix the numbers
in that the numbers in the entries
tell you how many paths there are uh
that go of that length of length two
that goes from j
to i in fact that's a beautiful
interpretation of an adjacency matrix an
adjacency matrix tells you
how many paths there are of length one
that just
a path of length one is just a path and
they're either zero or there's one
zero if there's not an edge one if there
is so
this is consistent but the square is
already kind of interesting um
and so for example i will spare you the
details and not to mention i would
almost certainly get it wrong
but if you squared this matrix here you
would get
assuming there's no typo here but maybe
there's not
you would get this matrix here super
interesting and
it's cut it's got zeros ones and twos
you know
that makes sense uh because if we talk
about the numbers of paths of length
two um sometimes there's not a there's
not a path of length two and that means
there's a zero here
but we can audit a couple of these um i
don't know
let's go from node four to three um
and that's going to be the a three four
that is right here and this is two uh so
apparently there are two
paths of length two that go from
node four to node three so let's let's
let's see if this is true oh now it's
the drum roll and we're gonna go
we're gonna go paths of length two from
four to three
okay so we're going to go from four to
three
and this here are the two paths of
length two one is you go from four to
three
and then you go on this oh i should say
that's called the self loop it's kind of
cool you can have a loop that goes from
yourself
from yourself actually to yourself
that's called a self loop
okay so that's a path of length two
here's another path of length two that
goes from four to three
first you go to five that's your
intermediary node and then you go on to
three
so it's cool and there are no others uh
that's what this is telling you
okay so that's that's what this tells
you
and so more generally if i take the elf
power of us
of a matrix which is the adjacency
matrix um
then it's fully interpretable as uh the
ij
entry is the number of paths of length l
from j
to i um so that's what this is
um ah there is a small typo there
oops okay um
good um our last topic is to show that
we can use
uh this powerful matrix notation to
super compactly
uh describe the qr factorization not the
algorithm
but the result sorry graham schmidt and
it basically turns out that graham
schmidt can be interpreted as
a matrix factorization and the truth is
that most people think of it
that way they i mean everyone has heard
of the gram schmidt
you know algorithm but mostly people
think of it as a factor
as a matrix factorization which is
called the qr factorization
let's see how that goes well um so what
i'll do is i'll take a matrix a
it's going to have uh it's going to have
a k
columns a1 through ak and they're n
vectors
i'm matching the notation from gram
schmidt okay so a
a has dimension n by k now if the
columns are linearly independent and i
run gram schmidt
then i get some orthonormal vectors
those are q1
through qk okay
and i'll define an n by k matrix q
and it's going to have these columns
right now we can very compactly say
that the columns of q are orthonormal
that's this equation it says that the
gram matrix of the q's is the identity
and
the on the diagonal it says that the q's
have norm 1.
on the off diagonals it says that the
q's are mutually orthogonal so this
you will you will henceforth when you
see the equation
matrix transpose times matrix equals i
you will know basically what it's saying
is the columns of that matrix are
orthonormal okay now from the
gram-schmidt algorithm
it says that a i is equal to
uh this that's a linear combination of
q1
up to qi okay um oh
by the way where the coefficient of q i
is actually
positive because q y tilde is positive
sorry q itility's non-zero and the norm
of q utility is positive
um and so we're going to simply call
those you know
r one i up to r i i
okay um now notice that a
i is a linear combination you don't need
more you don't need q
i plus two q y plus one these things
it's it's not they're not
and so what that tells you is that r is
upper
triangular the matrix r because we'll
take it to be zero for all the other
entries
um and then what happens is uh
is this you can write this equation out
in as this factorization it says that
you know
a here's a equals
a q here's q times
r right and not only that r is itself
r is upper triangular so it's only got
entries here
and on the diagonal it's got positive
entries so that's that's the picture
by the way this drawing i'm doing here
is actually a useful thing to do
it kind of shows you the dimensions and
allows you to keep them in mind and
things like that
okay so summary on this is that
the when you carry out gram schmidt on a
sequence of
vectors you and if
if you think of those vectors as being
the columns of a matrix
that's the same as factorizing that
matrix into a product
q and r q has columns that are
orthonormal and
r is upper triangular with positive
entries
on the diagonal and so actually people
refer to
you know qr factorization gram schmidt
interchangeably they're not quite the
same gram schmidt is
is if you like gram schmidt as an
algorithm for computing the so-called qr
factorization but this is how a lot of
people would
would talk about it also i guess if you
look in numerical packages for
linear algebra you probably wouldn't
hear anything about
graham schmidt however you would for
every single such package will have a qr
factorization
which of course is nothing but gram
schmidt expressed in
matrix notation
okay so this is the q so-called qr
factorization of a
um and it
right now uh you can't see there's no
reason for you to have any interest at
all in it uh
right now in fact graham schmidt i think
is a bit mysterious graham schmidt
the only use gram schmidt has at this
point in the book
it's only one is it's a way to to
computationally determine if a set of
vectors is linearly independent
okay now to which i am com
i am fully admitting the following there
is no reason
you should care about that at this point
because
like i don't know but what does it mean
for
vectors to be linearly independent does
mean the bridge doesn't fall down
uh i don't know we'll see later that
it's going to have a lot of important
things but for right now i'm just
admitting
it has no engine very soon you'll see
that this is actually going to be
it's going to have a lot of practical
implications i'm just admitting that we
haven't seen them yet